[DRUMMING]
[LAUGHS]
I promise you, I
can teach you how
to play drums in
about two minutes.
Uh, come on, here we go.
Here we go.
The first time I played,
I was five years old.
I learned how to play
by watching my dad.
This is the foundation
of who I am.
Every single piece of me is
in these drums, everything.
[DRUMMING]
One, two, three, go.
In this MasterClass,
I'm going to teach you
how to find your rhythm.
The fundamentals of percussion
and drumming, and how
to perform with a band.
Some funk beats can be a
little more complicated.
[DRUMMING]
It's still in time,
but it makes it funky.
Now this next beat
consists of three sounds.
So the first one is.
[DRUMMING]
And then a slap.
My right hand is
going to keep time.
[DRUMMING]
Someone said to me,
"You're a woman,
who said that you
can be the best?"
[DRUMMING]
I said "I can be the best."
Come on, uh!
If you don't have
drums, that's OK.
Pick up an instrument, do
something, play and enjoy
yourself and make it fun.
Because when you know
what your passion is
and what your purpose
is and you go for it,
no one and nothing
can stand in your way.
I'm Sheila E.
[DRUMMING]
And this is my MasterClass.
Play a little funk where the
MasterClass is in
the house, come on!